une nouvelle espèce dans nos gènes mêmes une
espèce que nous avons appelée Homo Naledi
Naledi signifiant étoile et la chambre que nous
avons appelée le dénominateur notre chambre
d'étoiles c'est une
espèce extraordinaire connue maintenant grâce au plus grand
assemblage de fossiles anciens jamais
découvert dans l'histoire de  notre science
et notre inconduite avec plus de 15
individus de tous âges, nous n'avons pas un
ou deux mais en fait un minimum de 15
individus squelettiques représentatifs
des gisements fossiles, ce sont quelques-uns des
ensembles dentaires les plus complets que nous
pouvons reconstruire à partir d'eux et une raison
pourquoi je voulais les montrer, c'est qu'ils
vous montrent une gamme d'âges en haut à
gauche, nous avons un
arrangement pour les très jeunes enfants et allant jusqu'aux
adultes très âgés en bas à droite, nous
représentons toute la démographie d'une population d'
âges d'oiseaux tous les  chemin vers la vieillesse
et nous avons des preuves anatomiques de
presque toutes les parties du squelette, nous voyons
une créature qui a un mélange fascinant de
caractéristiques un mélange de c  les caractéristiques
qui incluent des
caractéristiques inhabituelles comme ce pied qui a été trouvé
complet et en articulation en dépôt
montre une anatomie fluide très humaine un
pied très difficile à
distinguer à bien des égards de notre ennemi
il est très clair que les jambes et les pieds
d'Homo Naledi  ont été conçus pour une longue
distance et une marche efficace, ils ont
ce modèle d'activité semblable à celui de l'homme, c'est
la façon dont ils se déplacent à travers le
paysage, mais une main qui a
des os des doigts très incurvés plus incurvés que n'importe quel
membre de notre tennis incurvé de la façon dont
cela du  les premiers hominidés ont
probablement entendu parler d'
activités locomotrices comme l'escalade, mais ils l'
auraient fait avec leurs mains ainsi que
leurs jambes et leurs pieds comme je l'ai mentionné une
vie très humaine leurs mains un mélange de
caractéristiques primitives collectives humaines leurs dents relativement
humaines leur  des crânes comme le
propriétaire de l'école, mais contrairement à
ces autres espèces fongiques précoces, leur
cerveau est relativement très petit.
cerveau entre 450 et 550
centimètres cubes est un tiers de la taille
des cerveaux humains aujourd'hui est de taille comparable
domination précoce des événements colossaux
l'autre chose qui est importante est que
nous pourrions travailler nous dans les sénateurs et
ensemble ils finissent tous ensemble vers
le rang  de dédain et de penser à
la grotte à l'entrée de la grotte
et c'est le point que
nous avons actuellement au Decatur ainsi donc
l'es10 dans le palais les sédiments et
les fossiles contiennent du centre et
la décomposition exactement au même point est
ce que  nous entrons maintenant dans
le ainsi donc la morphologie de cette
chambre la forme de cette chambre n'a
pas changé avec le temps déjà je vous ai dit
nous seuls les répondants qui disent quelque chose
sur l'environnement pourquoi seulement les frelons
pourquoi rien d'autre le pape les
implications extraordinaires sur ce que le
le département ici est magnifiquement résisté,
il ne montre aucune trace de marques de coupure,
il n'y a donc pas eu de
bagarre entre les gens qui se
mangent  avec ces os ont soif, cela
ne montre aucune preuve de rupture par cupidité,
donc lorsque ces animaux se décomposent alors
qu'il y avait encore 11 villages récemment
morts, nous ne pouvons trouver aucune preuve sur aucun
de ces bols de marques de fromage ou de
marques de morsure économies il n'y a aucun dommage
il n'y a aucune preuve que c'était vraiment
ces os, il y a un dicton qui dit que
lorsque vous éliminez tout le probable, vous
êtes affecté par l'impossible, nous avons
éliminé dans la chambre dentaire l'
idée qu'il s'agit d'une mort de masse, nous avons
éliminé la possibilité de  une
catastrophe ces individus sont arrivés
un par un sur une certaine période de temps
ils n'étaient pas tous là ensemble ils
ne se sont pas lavés là-dedans ils n'ont pas été
déplacés par l'eau ils n'ont pas été mangés par
un super prédateur qui pouvait
passer à travers 18 centimètres
et  se faire nourrir uniquement à la maison avec une dame et
traîner ses corps dans la chambre profonde où
ils ne se tenaient pas aujourd'hui, il nous reste
également des données indiquant qu'ils n'y vivaient pas
il
n'y a pas d'archéologie là-bas  il n'y a aucun signe d'
habitation cette chambre n'a jamais été
ouverte sur le monde extérieur son
entrée a été difficile et elle-
même ne s'ouvrait que sur une autre
partie intérieure de la grotte le chemin pour se rendre à
cette chambre n'était pas facile c'était tellement pas
facile qu'aucune autre  les moyennes et
grandes urbaines avant pendant qu'elle
après cet événement pourraient en fait céder la place
à cette chambre et cela nous a conduits,
Mesdames et Messieurs, à la
conclusion assez remarquable que nous venons de
rencontrer une nouvelle espèce de parents humains
délibérément jeté ses morts à l'intérieur
de  le diable n'importe quelle chambre
l'impact de la venaison jusqu'à ce moment de l'
histoire, nous pensions à l'idée de
comportements ritualisés dirigés vers
les choses mortes comme l'enterrement ou l'
enior secret fait dans les chambres 2d était tout à fait
unique 200 cedis en fait peut-être
nous a-t-il identifiés c'était peut-être notre
chose singulièrement unique nous Néandertaliens
Homo sapiens archaïque un phénomène récent
qui nous a séparés du
règne animal l'idée que nous avons reconnu notre
o  notre immortalité et d'autres choses et que
nous ferions de grands efforts pour retirer les
amis, les parents et même les corps non apparentés
de l'environnement extérieur
et les éloigner de ce monde, nous nous considérions
comme différents, nous avons maintenant vu que
nous croyons une espèce que nous avons eue  même
capacité et c'est une
chose extraordinaire mesdames et messieurs je vous donne une
nouvelle espèce de fourmis humaines
pour apprendre pourquoi nous n'avons pas donné un peu
nous pouvons dire de la morphologie de Milet
qu'elle vient du temps profond elle vient de
la racine du  genre Homo et si notre
compréhension actuelle de l'âge de ces
origines est correcte sur la base de fragments
et de fossiles, alors l'espèce miletti
doit être âgée de plus de deux ans et demi à 2,8
millions d'années l'espèce et ne
signifie pas que les fossiles dans cette chambre sont
si vieux  mais nous ne savons pas quel âge
avez-vous ces fossiles